um i watched this in the sky sports news
newsroom full of journalists who
are also football fans for the most part
and no one had any appetite for football
there was a stunned silence as there was
more particularly around the stadium in
copenhagen
we saw as we're showing you on the
screen now
the denmark players forming a wall
around their stricken
teammate to give him some privacy as he
received
emergency treatment on the pitch he
collapsed without anybody challenging
him the ball was being played towards
him from a throw-in
and down he went and it was uh
exceptionally worrying quarter hour or
so
then around about half an hour or so ago
we saw started to see an image being
released which appeared to show
ericsson's eyes
open and him partially sitting up
as he was taken from the pitch but there
was still
some concern about how we should treat
that picture but as you say
there has been since then a statement
from uefa and another one from the the
danish
football union uh the latter saying
ericsson is awake
and is awaiting further examination in
hospital the
match temporarily postponed they said
uh uefa promised a further update that's
the european football governing body
at quarter to seven hour time that
hasn't happened
as yet so uh nick as you say some
reason for optimism because there's no
doubt that everybody in that stadium and
around the football world
was fearing the worst a lot of messages
support
on twitter including from the english fa
who said our
thoughts this evening with christian
erickson and his family and all
connected with the danish football union
the fa by the way cancelled
the news conference they were due to
hold with the manager gareth southgate
and the captain harry kane ahead of
england scheduled opening match at two
o'clock tomorrow afternoon at wembley
against croatia that
news conference was clearly going to be
inappropriate uh and was cancelled the
welsh chef a whales had a game
this afternoon themselves uh in the
tournament they said
uh we are praying for christian erickson
and his family and there was a similar
message in the last 10 minutes from the
scottish fa as well erickson has
a girlfriend sabrina quist and two young
children she's a hairdresser they spent
a lot of time in london together he was
seven years
at tottenham hotspur now plays for inter
milan he is the focus
of the football world this evening and
everybody just hoping that the more
optimistic signs that we've seen
in the last half hour lead to uh
recovery for
christian eriksen